OUR HEALTHDED N C ADVI MECE THEN
DISTRIBUTING THEHOULD
END OR CONTINUE. RES
OF BRAIN BLOOD AND WHETHER THER.
JOIN TO CORRESPONDENT DR.
SANJ GUPTA.
CHANCES THACCINE  TOMORROW BUTA
G THAT IN EXTREMRARE
CASES THE BLOOD CLOT CAN HAPPEN?
>> I THINK THASE THE
Y EN.
WE'LL SEE.
ONE THING EED IS
HAVING
THIS TIME OVER THE LAST WEEK O F
TO MAS WELL. OERA NEEDLE A HAYSR
ICEB HAVEN'T HEAF
IN SOME INSTANCES WHERE PEOPLE
MAY HAVE A PRE-EXISTING
COION, THIS MAY SERVE AS A
WAT THEY DID,
BYAY.
AG D THE EUROPEAN MEDICINE CHES
THAT SEEMS LIKE THST LIKELY
OUTCOME HERE, SOIN
>> THE WHITE HOUSE ANNOUYING TO
PLATEAUING BUSS
OFFERING INCENTIVES TO
BUSINESSES TO ALLOW EMPLOYEES T
GET TH
MANY PEOPLE REMAIN SKEPTICAL?E'.
ATPOIN STILL BOTH.
THERE ARE L LAS
ND THENT
HARDER TO AC
OPE NOT BEEN A
VACCINES.SEE VACCINHESITAY,CONF.
TH CAME OUT OF THE POLLING O
THE Y FOUNDATIONT % SAID EITHER
HAD THE CC
TO GET IT,E NO PROBLEM WITH
IT.
THEN LINE ARE PEOPLEY ONLY IF N
DEFINITELY NOT.
BUT THAT BLE
STARTED OFF AT A HIGH  O 17ATE C
E NUMBERS HAVE BEE
OT OF
THE FOCUS IS GOING TO BE.
A WILL THE OF THEM WANT TO WAIT
AND SEE, LET O PE D THEN THEY'I
PERCENTAGE FLIPS, THAT GETS US
CLOSE
COMMUNITY IMMUNITY.
>> Y SENIOSER TOHEHI A
SLE CDIS ING TO G AMERICANS LIK
COTOEAA  EXAMPLE
SCIENCE Y ABOUT
WHAT THE RULES S FOR
PEOPLE LIKE US, WHO E
VACCINATED?
>>ELL, LR SOME OF
THE
HE DA, O ARE
BOARD.NG INFECTED ARE GETTIN OUS
18.7, TH'SI SHAR, JAKE, THODOF
LIS
KEEP THOSE IN ND
OF YOUR MIND.rXU
LINDSAMA WRITES A LOOUT
THISIF YOU HAVANYOU ARE NOT VUL
MASKTHERE ISOM SENSEHAT
INTO PAS
IONARY FOR AERIOD OF TIME AND TH
TRA YOUR T'S SOMETHING YOU
CAN ECN THAT A RISK.
SKT YOU' GOING
TOATHE IE ELSEIR
SO OUTDOORS EN
VACCINAT, ORRY ABOUT
IFOU HIGH-RISK
AREA AND ARE CDE
HIGHK  MASK
IS STILL GOING TO BE A GOOD'.
F WEU D
I ARE BOTHE
IF YOU WERE TO GO TO THE DAVE
MATTHEWS, HE JUST
UNEN, WOULD YOU BE
TO WEAR A W WOULD NDLE
>> YH.K
I THLD BE
CUOUEE.
I BOUT THAT, TEYE
LARGE CONCERTS.
COUNTRY AT
POI
I THINK IN THE SUMMER --EEN OPS
COMFORTABLE GOING.IF, FOR WHATS
THESE CONCERTS -- AND  F , ONE
LOW VIRAL AN, I WOUL